what we are saying is that any
difficulty any tension and there are
always can be a must be resolved at a
table discussing finding dialogue
finding common ways and political no
unilateral steps we invite all to the
escalate the tensions and to engage in
direct dialogue also because the
European Union has a direct interest in
having the Gulf countries cooperating
among themselves they are all our
partners in the fight against terrorism
they are all our partners economically
they're also all our partners in trying
to solve some of the regional crises the
region is already fragile enough
dangerous enough we're starting to see
dangerous fear overs already both in the
broader region but also in Africa and in
Asia there are worrying signals so we
really invite to all to find a way to
solve any tension any controversies that
can be at a table discussing with
dialogue politically without excessive
ating tensions of course be the crisis
that in in the Gulf and obviously that
is something that we're working on very
hard together with our European friends
the French the Americans obviously
working very hard to try to bring the
sides together together get both sides
to dial it down I think we want to see
some progress that to lift the blockade
and to help the calories to explain
what's going on and and get a deal there
we are working very much with our
partners in the Gulf we had the
opportunity to open up the new trading
center at Kuwait just in January and we
still see real opportunities there to do
defence institution-building defense
capacity-building
working on important practical measures
such as cleaning up unexploded ordnance
improvised explosive devices that are
buried those kinds of very practical
areas but also helping to build defence
institutions so it's a great opportunity
and
we'll continue to do everything we can
to build and develop our cooperation
with our partners in the Gulf on a
short-term we need to support the
initiative of the coyote we need to
support Kuwait in such a role of a
mediation between the different actors
so it's very important to sustain
contact with all the partners and to
have a real dialogue but a median and
long term I'm sure that is a real task
maybe for the United Nations to try to
organize will the other between the
Shiites and the Sunnis not only in the
Gulf but in the entire region between
Iran and Saudi Arabia to give an example